hi my name is kostas and i will show you
the new intelligent features that we are
building in powerpoint so let's start
with the creating new presentation
starting with the blank presentation now
we can easier than ever before with a
new theme ideas feature in designer with
the new theme ideas feature I'm getting
suggestions right away when I create the
new blank presentation and as I click
through you can see what it brings to us
bring some really nice background photo
as well as the color scheme and fonts
that will be actually applied for the
whole deck so it means that if I decide
to choose this one and I create a new
slide in this deck as you can see it
follows the same theme the next feature
that we have recently developed in
designer in partnership with Microsoft
Research is bringing perspectives in
designer we know that different
resources showed us that memorizing and
understanding the large numbers much
easier when you're providing some
related value we are bringing
perspectives in designer which will help
much easier to comprehend and memorize
large numbers let me show you what it is
so when I talk about large numbers for
example I will talk about the Commercial
Airplanes which are which are flying at
30,000 feet
and in this case designer brings us not
just the ground image and different
style but also the perspective for this
number which is like that it's about the
height of the Mount Everest another
perspective which I really liked and it
represents how our features impact
productivity is related to the recent
milestone that we have reached in
designer we have more we have 1 billion
of kept slides by users so it means that
they actually use the slides provided by
designer and if let's say without this
user spend five minutes designing the
slide let's just imagine how much it we
save for our users in terms of time so
I'm gonna present that PowerPoint
designer saved five billion minutes for
our users
so in this case I'm getting perspective
for that number which clearly states
that it's almost 10,000 years so with
our feature which clearly indicates how
we help our users become more productive
we were able to save in total like
almost ten thousand years for our users
so let's move on and I will go to the
next stage so for me naturally after I
created the presentation I will go into
rehearsal mode so and with a new feature
called presenter coach I will be able to
get real time feedback on how I'm doing
and what I should do should improve so
basically talking about the solar system
exploration and as you can see in this
case it identified the fueler word which
I use a lot so I need to avoid using
this I mean so in this case we will
start with Mars another filler word
definitely should avoid and we'll start
with Mars and you guys must probably
know when we send the marina for there
but moving on to Jupiter I will talk
more about that I was talking too slow
so I need to speed up a little bit so
that it's much easier to comprehend what
I'm talking about so when the satellite
approached Jupiter he discovered a few
rings around Jupiter as well as volcanic
activity on the moon in this case
identified that I was actually reading
all of the slides and I will need to pay
attention to this so now you guys know
about the space exploration that has
been done and you can see that in the
end I will get the report on containing
the number of fewer words that I've been
using which filler words pacing so on
and so forth so this feature is using a
sure cognitive services which started as
a Microsoft resource project actually
another feature that is using it
ergative services is called life
captions/subtitles and here we are
moving on to the actual presentation
part in front of the audience so once
I'm ready to present the audience I am
before I'm going to start slideshow I'm
actually going to enable captions in the
real time so while I'll be speaking and
presenting to my audience they will be
able to see my words appearing on the
screen as I'm pronouncing them and that
will make my presentation much more
inclusive so that people or deaf or
hard-of-hearing can follow along the
presentation at the same time we want to
make this also inclusive for non-native
speakers that's why we support not only
captions which is same language text on
screen but we also support translation
with the 60 plus languages so let's say
I'm going to present to audience which
is fluent in Spanish and again in this
case I will be speaking in English and
my words will appear on screen in
Spanish in their almost real-time and as
you can see with the intelligent
features in PowerPoint we try not just
to improve authoring experience but also
make sure that we help users to become
better presenter and also make
presentation more engaging and inclusive
thank you